we're told that each rectangle is a hole
so this is a hole all right over there
that's one hole and so this is two holes
which expressions describe the shaded
part of the picture and they've shaded
in everything and they say choose to
answer so pause this video and see if
you can answer that before we work on
this together so before I even look at
the choices there's different ways I
could represent this I've I've already
talked about that if each of these
rectangles is a hole we have two of them
so I could say this is two holes that's
one way to represent it another way to
represent it is let's see each of the
holes is divided into two equal sections
so this is 1/2 right over there and this
is a another half this is 1/2 and this
is another 1/2 so total shaded in we
have 1 2 3 4 halves shaded in so we
could also represent it as 4 halves or
instead of writing 1/2 out like that you
could also represent a half like that
1/2 that's another 1/2 that's another
1/2 that's another 1/2 and how many of
these halves do we have we have 1 2 3 4
so how can we write 4 halves well you
can write it as 4 over 2 so which
expressions describe the shaded part of
the picture was definitely not just one
hole we have two holes here so I'll rule
that one out
4 has yep we already thought about that
one 4 halves
yeah we thought about that one as well
so we're done